they were assembled by the soldiers on a
featureless plain a great mass of
humanity looking for a way out
they are the wives mothers and children
of Islamic state and they have decided
to abandon their so-called caliphate
we were greeted with vacant stares and
dirt smeared faces and a collective
sense of fear what is it like in beggars
conditions it's always war said this
woman who fled the frontline in the
village of bug OU's people told us is
militants had agreed to let them leave
where it led nominee Leila is a teenager
and a mother of three it is an ordeal
that some here wish to forget but many
even the majority are devoted to Islamic
state and we were scorned as intruders
and infidels your face is like a shoe
said this woman
do you support Islamic state do you wish
you were still there do you support it
come on Bashar Allah as origin come on
Bashar a larger rocket o my beside
anonymous adorable [ __ ] the res res and
namazi for Kurdish LED forces for the
SDF the evacuees are a security threat
and a major logistical challenge each
adult must be screened then sent to a
giant displacement camp nine hours to
the north there are 5,000 people here
and I can tell you that it is completely
chaotic the women the children trying to
find space in these trucks their cattle
trucks used to move sheep around people
look tired and thirsty and utterly
disorientated some won't survive this
arduous journey for the passengers are
sickly and weak other than weeds and
some moldy bread there was nothing to
eat in Baku's they came in yesterday
afternoon into the night
and so that's David you Bay who heads a
group called the free Burma Rangers
let me put let me help him get in real
quick and then their volunteer medics
and they're trying to keep these people
alive he helped with four deliveries
last night Ilya delivered two of them
and then helped some others we've seen
probably 40 people shot here some wounds
were two days old some wounds were a
month old I can show you my phone no leg
bones sticking out in the back of the
trucks with no care
in a deferral difficult day yeah I think
it's it's always difficult because could
be you can be your kids many are defiant
and completely unapologetic but after
years of war and trauma they all need
help John sparks Sky News in northern
Syria